cette nuit la France a traversé une
tempête de feu
une tempête d'émeutes et de sa cage
des mairies incendiées des commissariats
attaqués
nos forces de l'ordre ciblées
par des violences inqualifiables
le poste de sécurité de la prison de
Fresnes ayant même fait l'objet d'une
attaque en règle
manifestement pour libérer des
prisonniers
les images de ces désordres sont
révoltants
et profondément choquant
trop de nos concitoyens
ont été tenus éveillés toute la nuit par
le bruit des tirs de mortiers
tirent de mortier on l'a vu sur
certaines images qui délibérément viser
des policiers
l'usage de Grenade et même évoqué
manifestement un seuil de violence a été
franchie
voilà le spectacle désolant
que la France a offert au monde cette
nuit
le spectacle d'un pays
ou une marée dénetiers est venue jeter
le chaos dans nos vies
ces actes criminels appellent une
condamnation ferme
et totale
rien
absolument rien
ne peut justifier
un tel déchaînement de violence
nous ne devons pas
abandonner la République
aux incendiaires
je veux ici témoigner de ma totale
solidarité et de mon entier soutien aux
forces de l'ordre aux policiers
au gendarmes aux pompiers
à tous ceux qui portent l'uniforme de la
République
et qui ont aujourd'hui la lourde mission
de s'interposer et de protéger les
Français du chaos
dans ce contexte
l'extrême gauche porte une très lourde
responsabilité
car l'extrême gauche a clairement appelé
à l'émeute
cette situation cette revendication ses
appels viennent couronner un projet
politique un projet de guerre civile
nourri par les appels répétés de haine à
l'encontre des forces de l'ordre
un projet de guerre civile consistant à
être lâchement complaisant avec les
ennemis de la République
tout en appelant à la haine de ceux qui
la protègent
le drame de Nanterre est aujourd'hui
entre les mains de la justice je fais
confiance à la justice
pour déterminer les responsabilités
et les causes de ce drame nous
comprenons bien sûr l'immense émotion
suscité par ce drame dont nous
reconnaissons la gravité
la mort de Naël
est un drame que nous ne méconnons pas
nous avons confiance en la justice et
nous souhaitons qu'elle puisse faire son
œuvre dans les meilleures conditions
pour cela
tous les responsables publics doivent
s'abstenir de déclarations hâtives qui
ne ferait que jeter de l'huile sur le
feu
mais surtout nous devons condamner
l'instrumentalisation de cette affaire
pour qui la mort de Naël n'est qu'un
prétexte à
nous appelons non seulement au calme
mais nous appelons à l'ordre à l'ordre
républicain à l'ordre restaurer et
réaffirmer
partout et entou lieu de la République
c'est pour cela que je demande
solennellement au président de la
République et au gouvernement de
décréter l'état d'urgence sans délai sur
la base de la loi du 3 avril 1955 pris
par décret en Conseil des ministres
cette loi peut concerner l'ensemble du
territoire où elle ne peut concerner que
des parties de ce territoire
et je propose qu'elle soit appliquée
dans les quartiers qui la nuit dernière
ont fait l'objet des plus graves
violences et des exactions les plus
condamnables
l'état d'urgence doit répondre à un
péril imminent
résultant d'attente grave à l'ordre
public il doit être instauré partout ou
des incidents ont éclaté nous devons
employer tous les moyens
que nous offre la loi pour poursuivre et
condamner les professionnels de l'émeute
et pour empêcher une nouvelle nuit de
chaos
si la nuit prochaine devait être le
théâtre à nouveau de scènes de désordre
de violence ce serait un échec lourd de
péril pour notre nation
j'appelle à la restauration de la paix
civile sur le territoire de la
République j'appelle à la restauration
de l'autorité de l'État j'appelle à la
sanction les plus fermes et les plus
impitoyables à l'égard de ceux qui cette
nuit ont voulu tuer assassiné des
policiers et des représentants de
l'ordre républicain merci beaucoup